christopher lloyd wants to know let's
start at the beginning how does
something like the sun
even form or come into being the way
that it is so in our in in the current
incarnation how does that happen yeah
cool of course this happens all the time
the galaxy has you know hundreds of
billions of these things called stars so
nature has no problem making these
things and the stars made of gas 100 of
gas and it comes from a gas cloud we
look now if we look through the galaxy
and didn't find gas clouds we would
wonder where do these where are these
things born but we find gas clouds it's
like looking around society and never
seeing a pregnant woman but you see
babies all over right you have to wonder
where your babies come from do you know
i feel the same way about pigeons but
anyway because you you don't see people
you never see these baby pigeons yeah
you're not alone one of the big
mysteries of life where's the little
pigeon
they're just they're just born holes
exactly
out of the egg it's a big pigeon so
either they're born quickly or you know
so you have to ask these questions but
society does have pregnant women and you
can judge how long they're pregnant if
you take snapshots of the culture so
that's what we do in the universe we
take snapshots of the galaxy at
different times and we find out there
are places where there are huge gas
clouds right gravity is gathering the
gas clouds into
it nucleates if you get one part of a
gas cloud that's slightly more dense
than another right it wins
it's got more gravity than anywhere else
and then it attracts more gas then it
has even more gravity so it's like
mexican food i can't i don't follow the
analogy
help me out on that one
well you eat mexican food yeah and it
causes gas which leads to more again
well i'd say there you go i missed that
one sorry that would be the bean part of
the mexican food
so yeah so if you have slightly more
mass slightly more density in your
region of a gas cloud than another you
are more likely to condense first and
then you win that contest and all the
matter comes to you eventually in the
center as the matter accumulates it gets
hotter and hotter and hotter it's under
pressure
gas clouds under pressure get hotter and
eventually it triggers thermonuclear
fusion and
a star is born look at that thermal
nuclear fusion there you go so it just
gets hot it bursts into flames busted
open i am so hot i'm just going back to
the flames yeah and it's thermonuclear
it's fusion energy it's not like fire
energy it's another kind of energy that
you derive from the nucleus of an atom
rather than from sort of molecules uh
breaking apart normal fire is just
molecules breaking apart that have
stored energy that releases it as fire
right this is different stars we say
stars burn but we don't mean burn right
we mean they're not on fire they're
thermonucleating yes exactly no that's
fascinating that's bad all right